ab dem ersten januar wird es wieder
gesetzliche neuerung geben und genau
diese wollen wir ihm jetzt einmal
vorstellen und zwar gemeinsam mit der
pressesprecherin von der
verbraucherzentrale nrw uns zugeschaltet
mechthild winkelmann um einmal darüber
zu sprechen
worauf müssen wir uns einstellen was
müssen wir wissen was ändert sich also
in wenigen tagen für uns alle und vor
allem wen beeinflusst das am meisten
ja es gibt eine reihe von veränderungen
auf die sich verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher einstellen können wichtige
stichworte sind dabei die neue
grundrente die abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags aber auch die neue
co2 die preiserhöhungen sorgen wird die
man gleich ab ersten januar an der
zapfsäule merken wird ja können sie dann
noch mal etwas genauer in die einzelnen
punkte vielleicht reingehen das ist
natürlich auch vor allem für den
geldbeutel oft interessant
beispielsweise die mehrwertsteuer die
würde ja jetzt wieder angehoben werden
auf der anderen seite aber der weg für
eine solidaritäts zuschlag was können
uns da sagen wen trifft es am meisten
wie viel geld habe ich am ende
vielleicht mehr im portemonnaie jetzt
zuschlag können sich rund prozent der
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler über
die abschaffung von nur 6,5 müssen ihn
noch teilweise zahlen und wenige top
verdiener weiterhin das heißt ein
alleinstehender mit einem mittleren
einkommen wird etwa um 930 euro im
nächsten jahr in bei der steuerschuld
durch gedeckt durch den wegfall des
solidaritätszuschlages entlastet werden
das merkt sie bemerkt macht sich ja
spürbar im portemonnaie bemerkbar
die mehrwertsteuer war ja eine
befristete geschichte die der
bundesfinanzminister
angekurbelt hat um die wirtschaft im
zuge der korona krise in schwung zu
halten oder zu bringen
wie wird die auch angekündigt zu ende
des jahres also zum silvester staat
jetzt auslaufen sodass ab dem neuen jahr
wieder 19 beziehungsweise sieben prozent
mehrwertsteuer fällig werden
sie haben die grundrente und das
kindergeld angesprochen ab wann fließt
denn da mehr geld und vor allem für alle
familien wichtig wie viel mehr geld und
ihr geld geht es gleich schlag erster
januar los dass das kindergeld für
januar wird angehoben und zwar für das
erste und zweite kind von derzeit 204
auf dann 2 119 euro das kind und monat
sind das 15 euro mehr für das dritte
kind sind es 225 und das vierte dann 250
euro über das sich familienfreund
außerdem wird angehoben der
kinderzuschlag den familien bekommen die
nur ein sehr geringes einkommen haben
da gibt es statt bisher 185 dann künftig
205 euro
vielen dank von winkelmann dass sie uns
das heute abend einmal so erklärt haben
und ihnen natürlich auch einen guten
rutsch ins neue jahr
dankeschön dankeschön gleich an
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren